What are angel investors and how can
they help you finance your business?
Angel investors are people who invest
their own money into a new business,
offering capital for
startup or expansion.
These investors usually aren't rich, but
like the idea of investing in startups
as an alternative to returns they could
be getting by investing in stocks.
Considering these motivations is
important when understanding some of
the benefits and
downsides of working with them.
So let's look at some benefits
of working with angel investors.
Here's three, investment amounts,
accessibility, and ease of engagement.
First, investment amounts.
Angels tend to be willing to invest
an amount of money that's great for
many startups.
As an estimate, it's possible to get
from as little as $25,000 to as much as
1.5 million for your startup.
Next, accessibility.
Angels can really be anywhere.
These are just people with some
extra money to invest looking for
the right startup to
get some good returns.
They could be right down the street or
at local meet-ups.
You'll find it much easier to get
in touch with angels than with
any other type of investor.
And finally, ease of engagement.
Once you've found an angel
who is interested,
it's generally pretty easy to
get through the paperwork.
You're also likely to get
paid in a single lump sum.
This can speed up the time it takes for
you to get some money and
start growing your business.
So those are some of
the benefits of angel investors.
Now, what are some of the downsides?
Let's look at three, high rate of
return, risk aversion, and control.
First, they'll want a pretty high rate
of return on their original investment.
You're competing with their option
to invest in the stock market and
if you don't provide enough growth,
they're probably not interested.
Next, risk aversion.
Angels aren't using expendable
income that they can afford to lose.
No one likes losing money, but the
financial situation of these investors
makes them particularly cautious
with the way they invest.
You're less likely to get an angel
investment if you have any high risk,
high reward type of plan for
your startup.
And finally,
because they want a high rate of return,
they can try to be pretty controlling.
Angel investors may want to be involved
in more of the decisions you'll make and
could end up affecting
the direction of your business.
They could be helpful, but be sure to
balance their advice with what you
believe is best for the company.
Angel investors can provide
an excellent opportunity for
growth in the early
stages of your company.
Take some time to consider the positives
and negatives of dealing with these
investors, then decide if
this option is right for you